[Música]
[Aplausos]
muy buenas qué tal nos suena de nada
porque no tenéis por qué pero mi voz a
lo mejor si buscáis en vuestra
conciencia en vuestra memoria sonora
puede que si yo soy actor doblaje actor
de voz nos gusta que suene mejor por los
actores del mundo dedicamos a la
publicidad al doblaje a la narración
seguramente habremos hecho vídeos
internos de alguna de nuestras empresas
dirigiste yo me lo comido yo hablándome
de las bondades de mi empresa un botón
de tiempo os puedo comentar contar cómo
está la oferta de la pechuga de pollo
fileteada en un hipermercado cercano os
puedo contar un montón de cosas pero
aquello que siempre suena más y por eso
esta camiseta es que yo soy fan del por
ejemplo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y vengo a hablar evidentemente pintando
la camiseta es un pequeño brunch y vengo
hablaros del camino del héroe el camino
del héroe es algo que os va a sonar
mucho más de lo que os creéis en muchas
historias y muchas muchas de las
películas muchas de las ficciones de las
que os habéis alimentado habéis visto
han comido de esa historia han seguido
esa historia
desde star wars si lo pensáis la idea
está empezando por la aliada hasta
nuestro querido harry potter todos han
seguido el camino del euro y lo
descubriréis poco a poco pero
sencillamente si lo simplificamos un
montón costaría de 4 pasos básicos el
primero el descubrimiento es anda tengo
algo diferente tengo algo que bueno voy
a ver de qué sirve como lo uso de que me
quemé para diferenciar la segunda sería
negación o abandono hay un hecho que te
indica que a lo mejor es en nuestro
camino oa lo mejor no te merece la pena
hay otra tercera que sería la aceptación
es bueno tengo esto vamos a ver que
consigo hacer con ello voy a hacerlo os
suenan algunas películas verdad y la
cuarta frase por ejemplo simplificar la
sería la ayuda a las demás bueno ahora
que tengo esto que hago con ello como lo
uso me puedo poder ayudar a gente si
está en ti puedes ayudar ser seguro de
alguna manera
yo no nací en gotham evidentemente yo
nací también en blanco y negro en parla
en una ciudad del sur de madrid en los
años 70 esas ciudades dormitorios las
que todo el mundo iba y por aquel
entonces les dais cuenta el los no había
esas actividades extraescolares que hay
ahora no los que todos procuramos tener
algo que nuestros niños pasan un ratito
si nos da tiempo a llegar con la lengua
fuera todos los padres y madres a
recoger los abuelos a recoger a los
niños en aquel momento las actividades
extraescolares se realizaban con las
asociaciones de padres de alumnos mi
padre era carpintero pues daba clases de
carpintería mi madre conocía muy bien
las clases de costura otro padre de otro
niño era había jugado al fútbol pues
obviamente el equipo de fútbol del
colegio todo centro pero en el fútbol y
otro era actor y trabajaba el doblaje y
bueno pues yo me tengo contra nube
teatro y a mí con seis años por el mismo
gracias esto de salir al escenario
pasártelo bien el psoe otro que como la
que divertido y me apunté a teatro
y ahí fue cuando de repente llegamos a
la primera fase de mi pequeño camino que
es el descubrimiento
con 12 años en el año 82
no haya ni canas en el 82 por aquel
entonces a la mayoría de los niños no
doblan mujeres y algunos chavales ven
una película que salían 200 niños
hablando y le dijeron ha estado director
de teatro jetta que a tus avales que por
lo menos son actores con adelante él es
de un micrófono pues oye no vaina vale
para ella que ponemos imaginaos un día
en el que no vais al cole con 12 años
pagan us 4 mil pesetas de la época te
pone en una sala de cine que será como
una tercera parte de estos llegas te
sientes y oyes esas voces pero yo
pensaba que los actores hablaban en
castellano
de hecho uno de los flashes que tuve fue
cuando una señora claudia me chocó no
era era curioso entonces en esa fase yo
estaba jugando a fútbol y estaba en el
grupo de teatro y de repente empecé a
hacer cositas de doblaje llegó un
momento en el que ya no daba abasto
y en la primera fase del descubrimiento
simple una figura de ser el mentor en
este caso fue director teatro pero y
otro mentor que en este caso fundamos
fundamental que fue mi madre hace caso a
vuestras padres que saben mucho
mi madre no vas a tener que elegir
porque estas sales del cole te vas a
ensayar salir del cole te vas a entrenar
salen los fines de semana partido y
luego por la tarde ensayó y luego
actuación tal base tiene que elegir tu
que quieres pero yo quiero salir en los
álbumes de cromos como todos no yo crea
el fútbol con mi madre esta frase tan
sabia de madre ni fútbol ni fútbol
te vas en el teatro bueno pues nada eso
a una escala al mínima a una escala
planetaria eso es lo que le pasó también
otro tiempo fue con una lesión tuvo que
dejar el fútbol por otra cosa que se
llamaba bueno este tipo le conoceréis
porque seguramente podría ser vuestro
padre y lo sabéis
a éste le pasó exactamente lo mismo pero
a una escala mucho mayor
uno de mis primeros papeles ese grupo
blanco es que todos habéis visto y que
ahora están reponiendo y que resulta que
la pone en los colegios oye me
congratula no saber que fui el capitán
pedrito en los anales del cuerpo humano
o érase una vez la vida constante esto
suena a todos a que sí y ahora además yo
tengo dos hijas de 14 y 15 años y hace
años en el colegio en papá nos están
poniendo una cosa es la que sale estudio
y ahora esto evidentemente noviembre que
grata sorpresa 16 años 17 dices hoy para
en aquellos tiempos imaginados sólo
había un canal bueno el segundo el autor
no emite a todo el rato no era como
ahora y había fines no había más y de
realmente llegar este gato
los trotamúsicos año 87 otra serie de
las que se veía porque sólo había un
canal y fue un pequeño regalo yo tenía
porque entonces 17 y lo hace los 18 años
y me ofrecieron contratarme no estudio o
sea dedicarme en exclusiva a mi trabajo
en el estudio vale voy a aprender estoy
aquí todos los días cuando trabajamos
todos los días y aprendo estuve seis
meses a los dos meses ya me di cuenta de
que yo eso estar de ocho a dos y media
sentado esperando que te llamaran aunque
el curro efectivo fuera una hora a veces
días de diez minutos
yo quería volar yo quería aprender yo
necesitaba con lo cual cuando acabe el
contrato dijeron claudito terreno vamos
dije no está igual yo tengo que tengo
que saber que hay aquí y me arriesgue a
lanzarme al mundo del del actor con 17
años y bueno que me llamen voy a seguir
estudiando y si me llaman puede ver que
tengo que hacer
y ahí entramos en una fase que fue
complicada la segunda fase del camino
era el abandono
17 años sales en mercadolibre crees que
estoy aquí
yo trabajaba antes con vosotros tal bar
decidió ponerme a hacer mil y una cosas
bueno que puedo hacer me puse a trabajar
a otro quería
no no me cuesta servir copas como todos
los actores que todos el resto aquí que
actor no servido copas pero bueno hay un
momento de crisis yo no sé qué va a
pasar con esto se va acerca del servicio
militar nos acaba de hacer la fase de
abandono en la que me planteó seriamente
volver a estudiar pero de repente me
llaman de un estudio oye hay una serie
nueva para nos han dicho que es un truño
pues ya verás es un culebrón tal esta
serie se llamaba conservar a lo mejor no
sólo me acuerdo del código que era
beverly hills 90210
si yo era el guapo pero el otro al que
le gustaban las tías estaba separando
era guapo pero a mí me gusta dylan
brandon fue un punto aparte porque de
repente con 19 años haces una serie en
el comienzo en las cadenas privadas en
las que de repente todo el mundo te oye
todo el mundo tiene ya nos hacían
entrevistas era algo 19 años sentado en
telecinco
y fue un punto y aparte luego siguieron
cosas como la aceptación cuando una vez
que te das cuenta que ya estás
vuelvo a estudiar no voy a estudiar
sensación de vivir fue un empuje muy
importante y dije bueno pues será que
esto es a lo que me tengo que dedicar
acepto mi propio camino y digo pues a
pelear por ello hace 9 20 años lancé
monos al vacío
trípoli el ayuda es enterprise wil
wheaton al que luego doblado en vivo en
flor y tristemente desaparecido en la
biografía
wil wheaton a más en esta época me pasa
una cosa muy curiosa llegaba justo al
servicio militar y yo no era conciencia
dije bueno yo no quiero de servicio
militar te estoy currando y estoy
empezando tengo que hacerlo me dice
objetor de conciencia y estaba haciendo
la objeción de conciencia y trabajando
es ahora por las tardes y yo por la
mañanas trabajaba cuando ya gracias al
boom de sensación de vivir el mercado
publicitario pero oye voces jóvenes está
este tío el que hace algo y nada en la
serie de referencia venga vale estos
chavales fue cachondo que durante esta
serie me llaman de estado trabajando por
la mañana siguiendo por la tercera
prestación social me llaman hoy una
campaña a una pasta ya verá hasta los
que venga venga así que es el tren del
ejército
y bueno un héroe no tiene por qué ser
coherente le dije que si era autónomo al
xerez hay que hacerlo ese fue el primero
salvado el mundo de un meteorito vale
ben affleck aquí estaba más joven y más
más joven estaba bueno esta película
demás es una de las películas que
siempre los reto que lo probéis cuando
la pone en televisión de mejor manera en
otra vez
impresionante y le han puesto mil y una
veces vale pero siempre bueno salvar el
mundo del meteorito pues tiene su rollo
le volvió a doblar en el harbour otra de
esas películas que todo el mundo ha
visto mil veces que cuando lo pone en
televisión te quedas a verla fue una
película además las primeras copias que
nos llegaban antes de antes doblamos con
todas las copias finales y recuerdo con
estas copias por ejemplo nos venían las
imágenes y los aviones se van a sitios
le faltan las hélices faltan todo
entonces que nos el material final
espérate que somos la cola del mundo ya
llegará el harbour fue una película muy
interesante a ver
después fue llega el primer héroe me
llaman un día en el estudio y yo llega
una película de superhéroes yo que desde
los 16 años en aquellos momentos se
cobraba en metálico y al día tenía dos
compañeros actores imaginaos el metal y
al día yo salía al metro me compraba
tebeos de val de batman siempre pero de
repente ex ven que era mi segundo
superior inferido me llaman para hablar
allí es más de en el ciclo médico esto
es un regalo tío yo lo aproveché y ahí
está doblando le unas cuantas películas
fue un médico buenorro macizo
si este tío además siempre que hablamos
de esta serie dicen alto doblas al
doctor macizo
bueno te pareces en nada
no nos parecemos en nada pero para mí
voy de decir que somos de la misma
altura casi vale somos eso sí guapo el
tío tiene un magnetismo bestial una de
estas personas todas estas historias
todos estos papeles siguen llegando
llegamos al mundo del videojuego y hace
años me llamó para hacer el primer
videojuego que tenía un motor de imagen
de no sé qué altair en assassin's creed
que luego dio origen a toda una saga el
camino sigue sigo creciendo sigo
madurando y te vas abriendo diferentes
mercados para que les está presentando
algún evento el mundo de los videojuegos
sigue atacando este es el último por
ejemplo days con una exclusiva de
playstation para que os hagáis una idea
antes eran 20 30horas yo para este
videojuego estado 100 horas grabando 100
horas grabando solamente oyendo el audio
original sin ver absolutamente nada ya
que si sois jugones y no jugáis contame
qué tal porque no he visto nada no está
absolutamente nada llegan los juegos
llegado en un punto en el que mercado se
está abriendo para nosotros los actores
es enriquecedor
casualidades de la vida doble a
christian bale lo va haciendo a batman
en la trilogía de christopher nolan y
cuando aquello acaba de repente oye que
han elegido a ben affleck y yo para
warner había hablado a ben affleck
dijeron queremos que seas tú soy vamos
aquí estoy hicimos estas películas van
damme versos y superman alega la
justicia todo todo rula todos y que se
descuenta me salta uno de los de mis
favoritos luego va quien ha visto luego
batman que no ha visto con sus hijos al
final este es el típico personaje que
además ha traído me ha traído más
conocidos padres que niños niños eran tu
padre doblegó hambre pero cuando las
papas llevaban al cine a los niños
una frase de esto al final ha sido uno
de los de siempre las diferentes
versiones de batman en las películas
animadas que he tenido gusto y placer el
poder doblar es también una apuesta muy
curiosa banda niña si os gusta el
universo de la bestial han hecho
diferentes batman a la luz de las han
hecho diferentes y en todas he tenido la
suerte de estar ahí bueno de momento los
videojuego batman recuperó las analizó
lo llevamos a arrancar una saga de
videojuegos que es la saga arkham
también contaron conmigo con lo cual la
franquicia sigue dice es bueno tal no sé
qué me dijo el dato hace poco pero es el
tío que más veces ha encarnado a batman
más que troy baker más que kevin conroy
debut debe ser no sé no más he contado
algún día les contaré cómo tenga tiempo
todo esto sigue creciendo y el camino
continua y un momento que te planteas yo
tengo ya casi 50 49 años estudia en la
cara b dlp de la vida que algunos hablé
con él en la tele pero qué puedo hacer
con todo esto que he hecho yo para
merecer lo que tengo
aparte de trabajar hay una frase que
dice poco en una en un disco de un grupo
muy bueno es el círculo ceano que era la
suerte se mide por el número de intentos
yo he intentado montar varios negocios
he intentado montar una compañía e
intentado montar x negocios y siempre al
final la suerte era esquiva pero bueno
cuando reúnes a la gente adecuada el
equipo necesario es ahora quiero ponerme
en modo ayuda yo ya estoy bien ya puedo
resumir puedo vivir con poco quiero
crear el modo ayuda que es el final del
camino del euro en el que la literatura
y las y en el cine ha sido el final
camino negro que es el modo ayuda pues
como pues te lanzas a la aventura
empresarial y a día de hoy
tenemos 20 personas
en 33 ciudades sólo lo hice madrid
barcelona lisboa 20 personas trabajando
cientos de personas colaborando con
nosotros trabajando para nosotros era el
modo ayuda era lo que yo podía hacer si
hubiera sido panadero habría montar una
franquicia panaderías pero eso lo que
sabía hacer vale
el camino del oro además no acaba el
camino del euro es un recorrido todos y
cada uno de vosotros si nos descuenta
analizarlo el camino del héroe no
termina porque consiste en mantenerse el
verdadero éxito es mantenerse en el
camino por eso todos y cada uno de
vosotros tenéis vuestro propio camino y
os animo a que lo continuáis porque
además como diría mi último personaje
muchas gracias y que viva los zeppelin
[Música]
[Aplausos]